Hi, my name is Bradley Gillow.
I’m a young filmmaker from Australia and
I’m currently directing a film called TO
CATCH A BUNYIP.
When I was a kid I’ll always remember seeing
a camera around because my Dad used to video
tape all of my baby videos.
I don’t know, it was something that I always
thought was interesting you know the phrase
A Picture Paints A Thousand Words.
I like to imagine that film does that a thousand
times more than photography.
That kind of sparked an interest for film
for me.
By the time I was six I was just watching
movies constantly and the films that I would
watch the most were adventure films.
TO CATCH A BUNYIP is basically a film about
this young girl Emma who goes to the Billabong
every day because she believes that the Bunyip
lives there and she wants to capture it for
its magic (she believes that Bunyips have
the power to regenerate life).
She wants to get the magic because she wants
to help her sick Mom Jess who suffers from
Parkinson’s Disease.
Her older sister Abbey clashes with Emma because
she doesn’t believe in Bunyips and that
what Emma is saying is nonsense.
She wants to have Emma share more responsibility.
What made you want to tell this story?
Bradley: This film that I’m making is a
personal story that I’ve wanted to convey
for about three years now because my Mom had
Parkinson’s Disease and it had a significant
impact to the way that I was growing up as
a kid.
When I graduated from high school my Mom passed
away from her 12-year battle with Parkinson’s
Disease.
And for about two years I was depressed because
I wasn’t really sure where my life was going
after that.
I wanted to make this story to convey my feelings
on that experience as well as sort of an outlet
for me to get over those feelings and move
on.
The reason why I incorporated Bunyips, there
was a film that I watched when I was a kid
called Dot and the Kangaroo, that was a film
that I used to watch with my Mom.
And I wanted to turn this bad situation into
something more light-hearted so I immediately
thought of that film.
That film happens to feature a Bunyip.
I wanted to enjoy my inspiration from that
memory in particular and make a film where
it comes from a very bad place into a more
light-hearted adventure film.
The story is not so much about the Bunyip
but rather the family.
Yet the Bunyip is all a part of this and is
the link to the family.
You don’t see the Bunyip per se, but I’ve
written it in a way that it’s left for interpretation
whether the Bunyip exists or not and it’s
something for the audience to decide on.
This is the first short film I’m directing.
I’ve done directing in the past where I
was not 100% sure what I want or what I’m
going for but with this I have this clear
idea in terms of every small detail from production
design, cast, locations.
I feel pretty confident as a director to do
my job well.
I’ve spent so much time just thinking to
myself all the small details of how the scenes
are going to play out, how the shots are going
to look, how the performances are going to
play out during the scene.
Obviously there are going to be issues that
are going to pop up while filming but I think
I have enough preparation to be ready for
the shoot and because of that I think that
this will turn out really good.
In terms of the production of this film, so
far it’s been pretty challenging to say
the least because I wanted to have this film
set in the 1970’s.
The probably with that is there’s not a
lot of locations that are still in that era.
So I was very worked up about finding the
right location that worked.
I feel like I’m finding places that are
perfect it’s just that it’s taking the
time to find the right place that fits within
the film that would also have the right
paints, textures and I think it’s worth
the wait of finding the right location rather
than shooting over at a mate’s place because
it shows that there’s a lot of attention
to detail.
During the course of our production it felt
like I was reliving those moments when my
Mom passed away because the way that I wrote
it was such a vivid part of that experience
and it was during those memories where I felt
alone during the course of our writing, developing
the story, finding locations, casting it felt
like I was very much in the moment of that
pivotal day and when I pitched the film that
same night my Nan passed (who is my Mom’s
Mom) and it felt like I was reliving pretty
much those days.
But it’s good in a way because I believe
with that I think I’ll be able to direct
my head-of-departments and my actors to bring
them with me in those days.
I’m definitely sorting things through and
I have a really strong team behind me who
makes this film run smoothly as well.
It definitely helps me knowing that they’re
there for me as well.
As I said before this story is about family
rather than the adventure that the protagonist
is having.
So for me it was important to find people
that looked relatively the same.
The youngest girl Eva is brilliant.
Eva was the second girl we auditioned for
the protagonist role of Emma.
I immediately told the producers that she
was the one and we pretty much casted her
straight after that.
One of the characters in my film (Jess) I
wrote her to intentionally have Parkinson’s
disease and this character is very important
to me because she is based on my own Mom and
I wanted to get my feelings off my chest into
this one character that means a lot for this
story and for myself.
I wanted to find someone who was really good
at body performances and someone who was willing
to study how Parkinson’s affects you mentally
as well as psychically.
And we came across Mel and she was very genuine
and it felt like she was perfect.
The rest of the cast was great, as well to
help sell the idea that everyone is a family
and I believe they’re perfect.
This film is sort of independently raised
at the moment out of my Mother’s inheritance
because I believe that might as well use what
she gave me to help make her film.
The end goal with this film (like I said before)
I kind of want this film to be viewed as as
a quintessential film for Parkinson’s disease
where the patients can watch and it’s something
that they can relate to.
I think the most important thing about this
film starts with the story because that’s
pretty much the blueprint of any film and
if you don’t have a good blueprint than
you don’t have a good film.
I made sure to make the script as tight and
as vivid as possible so when someone reads
it they get a good sense on how everything
is going to play out and I made sure that
I’ll leave room for actor’s interpretations
so that they can get into their roles more
and it doesn’t have to be dialogue fro the
script but something that comes from themselves
personally.
I feel like I’m not in the position to give
anyone advice because I’m still learning
but make films that you personally want to
make.
I don’t think you have to personally experience
something to make a good film.
If you’re willing to put in time and effort
to research into a particular idea I think
if you believe in that film then it could
be possible to make it happen and make it
a really good film.
One more question.
Bradley: Yes.
Sure.
Are Bunyips real?
Bradley: I like to think so but I haven’t
seen one.
I’m sure they’re out there…somewhere.